et voilà le secret de son pseudo est
dévoilé zep le créateur de titeuf
répondait en dessin aux questions du
public à rambouillet pourquoi la
maîtresse a des cheveux bleus pourquoi
nadia ne sort pas et titeuf ou encore
comment être ses idées il ya un côté
comme un comme un musicien qui
viendraient improvisé et moi j'aime bien
ce côté jean-claude le dessin à côté
spectaculaire que pendant très longtemps
on n'avait pas utilisé parce que
techniquement c'était compliqué de venir
dessiner on dessine petits et les gens
et parloir de loin donc on dessinait sur
des paper board
je trouve que l'exercice est assez
marrant ça évite aussi de brouiller
parce que trop bien la tendance à
fonctionner sur des mêmes idées et là on
sait pas je sais pas ce qui m'attend
sous silence attentif dès les premiers
trait de feutre mais éclats de rire à la
découverte du dessin dans le public des
petits comme des grands
c'est pas si loin du cours parce qu'on a
envie de profiter encore de ses dessins
mais super échange on en apprend un peu
plus sur lui et surtout qui n'a pas que
titeuf et que sa mère artiste c'est un
peu grâce à lui que actuellement je fais
des études de bd il est de tout ce qu'il
a fait dans le monde de la bd ça fait
vraiment plaisir de voir quelqu'un
encore aussi motivé c'était très bien et
un drôle et souvent et qu'il dessine et
très bien et je veux en faire mon métier
plus tard
ça fait plaisir de pouvoir voir un
auteur de bd célèbres
une personne qui a beaucoup d'humilité
cette première rencontre dessinée de la
lanterne a rassemblé près de 200
personnes une vingtaine de chanceux est
reparti avec un dessin original et si
vous aussi vous voulez savoir comment
titeuf fait tenir sa mèche voilà la
réponse
[Applaudissements]